during the pandemic when i was in some
dark moments i'd watch like these
five-minute youtube videos of viktor
frankl talking and suddenly i felt
enthusiastic about life
and and yet if you take viktor frankl's
core message
of empowerment which i think is the
larry elder message you know that you're
describing as well
which is that you can change your life
you can take control and responsibly
your life but if you but but somehow
progressive said that's fine for
self-help but in politics it's blaming
the victim
to suggest that people have control over
their lives to suggest that people of
responsibility and agency and
empowerment was viewed as blaming the
victim and boy what a disservice
and what a destructive view this idea
that you should categorize people as
victims and suggest they're powerless
it seems to me that if you have this
sort of secular idea on steroids this
you know government's going to do
everything on steroids it leads to this
sort of crazy neuroticism because
government can't solve all of your
problems and you're constantly looking
to it as you would
god or whatever it is that you believe
in i'm wondering if that tracks with
where you're at sort of politically too
because i've seen a bunch of my liberal
friends that are on a similar trajectory
as me that now are either believers that
weren't believers or are at least
questioning or something along those
lines
oh yeah for sure you know and i think
that like you know i want to distinguish
between
the progressive activists who are based
have the victim ideology and control
policy to some extent a large extent at
the state level in terms of housing
first aclu those folks want to
distinguish from them and you know say
my hairdresser who voted for bernie
sanders who also is upset about the
homeless situation the open drug scenes
she's more in that 70 to 80 percent that
i think would favor a more balanced
response of both carrots and sticks in
terms of a shelter first treatment first
approach rather than a housing first
approach
so i think the challenge again i think
it's a there is a leadership problem i
mean you need to have somebody who can
articulate that vision and explain it to
people because you know when you get
people
in a conversation like a focus group
rather than in like an ins you know if
you're using type 2 thinking slow
thinking rather than fast thinking i
think people are more
attentive to the need for a balance that
it's you shouldn't just be able to you
we still have a very deep reciprocity
you know motivation which is if you give
somebody something you should expect
something in return progressives are
violating that in this idea of you just
giving
street addicts anything they want and
not asking for public order and public
behavior in return so that seems to me
that's the soft underbelly of the
progressive agenda in california
honestly i think it's the soft
underbelly of democrats nationwide i
think republicans should be doing a lot
more with it which is that you know here
this big package this big budget package
is going to give what a couple more
years of college education some child
care credits but what's it doing about
like the most important
cause of death uh accidental cause of
death i mean here the fda finally issued
a one pill can kill
advisory but i mean like we're seeing
you know kids are kids who experiment
with thinking they're taking a half a
percocet buying it from a dealer on
snapchat or dying in their bedrooms
being found by their parents i mean this
is michael k williams the great actor
from the wire who died from fennel
poisoning
prince tom petty i mean you know
fentanyl changes everything in terms of
this is not just an addiction problem
we're now dealing with with active
poisoning and democrats are just not to
be found anywhere i'm dealing with this
so i do think there is room for maneuver
i do think it's a dark moment right now
but there's so much chaos in the system
in the last four years we've seen that
that something is going to change that
the system can't maintain its
instability
for for many more years i think
republicans are moving in a lot of the
issues that you and i i think
probably had concerns with republicans
over 10 or 20 years or just not issues
anymore you know um i see the progress
that's you know like one of the
characters in my book
um is harvey milk the gay rights leader
um i asked my my publisher i was like
are my conservative readers gonna have a
problem with harvey milk and he was like
no i mean it's like that issue is gone
so a lot of the social issues seem to be
taking moving to the background and we
see
new issues coming to the forefront that
i do think open up possibilities for
some challenge to progressive orthodoxy
you know it's interesting as you were
mentioning that i may have told you this
story three years ago but when i had
interviewed david horowitz the first
time and david horowitz was sort of the
original why i left the left guy he told
a story about how you know he was
marxist his whole life a leftist his
parents were communists and then in 1984
he liked reagan during the re-election
so he says you know basically i'm
leaving the left and then he told me
this story about how
in new york at the peak of the aids
crisis that all of the public health
officials who basically they were
lefties it was run by mostly democrats
that they all knew that it was emanating
from the gay bath houses like they just
knew people were doing drugs there they
were having unprotected sex and they
knew it was all coming from there and
they knew that all of these people young
people were dying every day hundreds and
thousands were dying and that the
conservatives who had really no power
the republicans in new york city came in
and said well okay we gotta close the
bath houses that's how we have to do
something here and it was the democrats
who said no because they didn't want to
infringe on you know on those people's
lifestyle to be thought and they called
direct they called them homophobes
basically anyway i'm just reminded of
that because it's so consistent with
everything that you're saying here
yeah because they were because they were
the victimization or the spread the
spread of hiv aids was occurring at the
individual level rather than something
being imposed by the system and so yeah
i think that you have to remember
progressives start from the point of
view that the system is evil you know
and it's basically a russoin idea that
the individual is innocent and good and
that the society is what's corrupting
and conservatives just to really dumb it
down to kind of big crayon level and
conservatives are more like humans are
fallen and
and um and society is what keeps us on
the straight and narrow and i think
that's still very much alive here it's
why it's why we allow people to be
killed by drug dealers
um killed by civilians but we you know
are
you know just everything changes when
people are perceived as being victimized
by the state right like literally if you
if you bring up black on black crime
they'll tell you you're a racist i mean
that's your point yeah
yeah and i mean here's the interesting
thing and i i find i i was i'm
interested in hearing your view of it
too i mean
to declare all black people victims
that's totally racist and the idea that
all white people are privileged is also
racist and when you really kind of
listen to it for a minute you go so let
me get this straight you're saying that
all white people are privileged and all
black people are victims
and that you think that's not racist
it's the most racist thing
victimology is actually bigger than that
of course it encompasses that kind of
racism but it also suggests
that a whole set of other people are
basically that people are powerless you
know that people that you put in the
category of victims are powerless and
therefore
and one of the consequences of course is
it is that we shouldn't do anything to
prevent them from being victimized
because doing so would only exacerbate
the victimization
one of the
sorry go ahead well you no no you know
my feelings on this but i'll tell you
this look i have larry elder coming to
my house for dinner tonight larry elder
born in south central dad was a janitor
does not view himself as a victim and is
not a victim and i have one of my best
friends from childhood whose son right
now who's white
which it doesn't matter other than for
the purposes of this story his son is
hooked on fentanyl right now and and he
you know and it's like he grew up
privileged and that is that out of job
so it's like none of this makes any
sense i'll give you you know i'll tell
you something i was i've been obsessed
with this um with one of the fathers of
cognitive behavioral therapy named
victor frankel who is famous because he
wrote a book called man search for
meaning he's one of the original
humanistic psychologists
of the 1960s
his whole book man's search for mean is
about how he survived the concentration
camps
under the nazis and he did so by
changing his mentality and getting a
goal and his goal was you know survive
the concentration camps um uh uh find my
wife and parents
and read and write a book about the
experience and he so his whole thing was
mentality mentality mentality forget
about how bad the situation is mentality
is everything
and he was loved by progressives in the
60s viktor frankl's book man searched
for me and he sold like 10 million
copies it's this incredibly i during the
pandemic when i was in some dark moments
i'd watch like these five minute youtube
videos of viktor frankl talking
and suddenly i felt enthusiastic about
life
and and yet if you take viktor frankl's
core message
of empowerment which i think is the
larry elder message you know that you
were describing as well
which is that you can change your life
you can take control and responsibility
your life but if you but but somehow
progressive said that's fine for
self-help but in politics it's blaming
the victim
to suggest that people have control over
their lives to suggest that people of
responsibility and agency and
empowerment was viewed as blaming the
victim and boy what a disservice
and and what a destructive view this
idea that you should categorize people
as victims and suggest they're powerless
well that's why i always say it's
anti-human actually because the one
thing that separates us from the animals
is our re is our ability to logic and
reason and dream and pursue and have
passion for something and build that was
a lot of things that i combined into one
thing but like that's the thing that's
the thing and they're and they're saying
no it's not yours it's ours to somehow
give to you
and that seems to me um in terms of uh
fighting back against the radical left
and the dehumanization that you're
describing and the disempowerment that
seems to me to be the soft underbelly as
well we i think have a natural instinct
to not want to perceive ourselves as
victims in fact in the book i describe a
fair amount of homeless guys will
confess that they were just playing the
victim that they don't actually perceive
them homeless guys living in the streets
don't actually perceive themselves as
victims and i think in part because it's
like that's a terrible way to live it's
a it's it's a depressive way to live and
it's hard to sustain it
um they might pretend that for a bit but
i think that really you're on to
something really powerful here which is
and i think that you know all of your
work honestly dave has been really um
uh creative and productive when you're
talking about this question of of
psychological health
that the extension of psychological
health in one's own life in politics
should be one of empowerment
um i don't think that means that um you
know i think when it comes to things
like health care that we we still may
need a universal psychiatric program
but it has to be paired with with this
idea that people are capable of taking
responsibility for their lives even
people frankly with disabilities and
addictions and in all sorts of terrible
circumstances all the more reason
that they should be empowered to take
power and responsibility for their lives
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell